republicans are increasingly endorsing a
conspiracy theory according to the
left-wing rag slate.com
and it is apparently
all my fault
i your humble host am now officially a
conspiracy theorist according to
slate.com get me a tinfoil hat bring me
my gay frogs i have apparently led
republicans astray
by persuading them to sign on to my
public health protection pledge
which slate alleges makes a boogeyman
out of dr anthony fauci and links him
quote to an ominous history with covid19
that is the headline
to date wright slate
more than a dozen congressional
candidates have signed this pledge which
was authored by the daily wires michael
knowles
this is true
sitting members of congress have
endorsed my pledge too by the way so
it's not just the candidates it's
actually members of congress congressman
paul gosar introduced it as an official
house resolution just this month so that
part's totally right what's the
conspiracy theory that i'm peddling you
might ask what is the accusation that i
have made well slate slate continues
they say
to be clear the pledge itself makes no
specific accusations
of wrongdoing
huh it's kind of weird slate accused us
of peddling a conspiracy theory but then
immediately admitted that we did no such
thing we didn't peddle any theory at all
slate then focuses the rest of the
article on what it calls the gain of
function
conspiracy theory that is it describes
quote an idea that incorrectly connects
u.s funding that was used by the wuhan
institute of virology to study bat
coronaviruses to a theory also incorrect
that the institute created and leaked
covid19
now the strange thing about the
incorrect conspiracy theory that that
slade is talking about
is that it is a pretty well established
fact which even slate admits just a few
paragraphs later conceding that quote
fauci funded an experiment at the wuhan
institute of virology in which a
modified coronavirus proved unexpectedly
infectious at which point quote the nih
pulled funding for the project
slate goes on to admit that the
experiment that was indirectly funded
could actually have been classified as
gain of function according to several
experts and that
there is legitimate scientific debate
over the merits of conducting such
experiments on viruses because of their
potential to spread disease or start
pandemics
did the virus come from the lab
many leading public health officials and
experts say yes it very very possibly
very likely even did in other words
after defaming me
and dozens of republicans as conspiracy
theorists
slate admits that we aren't endorsing
any particular theory at all and the
theory we might have endorsed is true
we could much more plausibly accuse
slate and the rest of the left-wing
media by the way of being conspiracy
theorists but that wouldn't be quite
fair because they know better than the
nonsense and the bile that they are
spewing they admit it after the headline
they know that we are raising the right
questions and telling the truth
that is why they're lying and libeling
us and that is exactly why we've got to
keep pushing because these crooks and
liars are showing us that we are right
over the target i'm michael knowles as
the michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from robert
roodhouse who says the hand that rocks
the cradle is the hand that rules the
world
but libs of tick tock is showing how
many of those hands are actually shaking
the baby
what
what an apt and precise metaphor what we
have a generation now
probably two generations
of shaken babies that's true the hand
that rocks the cradle is the hand that
rules the world and when the hand is
malicious or misguided or not up to the
task civilization
starts to fall apart
it's not good i mean you're seeing this
especially here in our own country where
we're outsourcing everything where we're
throwing away american jobs all those
good american products we used to have
we're just sending them overseas getting
inferior product which is why i would
strongly recommend you check out good
ranchers did you know that 85 of
grass-fed beef in the united states is
imported from overseas that's right even
if it says product of usa on it that
doesn't really mean it's from america if
it's minimally processed here they get
to say that and then you're going to be
paying a premium for overpriced
foreign low quality meat don't do that
head on over to good ranchers good
rancher says 100
american meat delivers it right to your
door at an incredible price i love it
too because one the meat is exceptional
i eat it all the time the steaks the
hamburgers the chicken but the way they
is they package it individually because
so much meat in this country just gets
thrown out it's just completely wasted
because of packaging this one you're not
going to waste it because it tastes too
good but two you're not going to have
too much and then you got to throw it
out later you're going to save money on
both sides of that head on over to
goodranchers.com knowles today solve
your meat problem once and for all get
the transparency quality and cuts that
you've been craving order now with code
knowles get 30 bucks off your box
now is the time to support american
farms and ranches they're hurting you're
hungry solve both problems with a box of
american meat delivered whoever buys
that meat in your house go to
goodranchers.com
knowles today
the culture war issues are winners
for a long time you heard from the
squishy republicans don't talk about the
culture war
don't talk about abortion don't talk
about immigration don't talk about
marriage don't just don't it's just
going to turn people off all you got to
do talk about cutting taxes that's all
people want to talk about and then leave
all the other stuff away and that's how
you win elections
that's the mitt romney strategy
that's the john mccain strategy
that's the jeb bush strategy you
remember the romney administration right
and the
jeb administration and the mccain oh no
all those guys lost
their strategy was a losing
strategy i've been saying this for a
long time now one of the biggest culture
war issues is dr fauci actually is
the
medical bureaucracy that's taking away
our rights and our liberties and our way
of life and forcing us all to take this
experimental drug
and leading a pandemic on that was
supposed to last two weeks and now it's
going on years and years indefinitely
that's a culture war issue we don't like
the culture of some petty little
bureaucrat running our lives and
upending our constitutional order and
what the same squishes say oh no stop it
stop talking about the vaccine mandates
and that's just so icky just talk about
cutting taxes the culture war issues are
winners the the bean counting egghead
issues are losers okay the squishes are
dead wrong and even the democrats know
that
the smart republicans know that the
democrats know that the only people who
don't know that are the squishes the
d-triple-c that's the democrat
congressional campaign committee one of
the most prominent democrat opera
operations in the country they just sent
out a study
that that concludes
that the culture war
is alarmingly potent
for
republicans politico reporting on this
now
the campaign committee has been showing
house democrats polling about how to
counter gop attacks on various issues
they say that the
that they need to more forcefully
confront the gop's alarmingly potent
culture war attacks from critical race
theory to defunding the police they risk
losing significant ground to republicans
in the midterms
this is not just
some democrat propaganda out there put
out to the public where you might be
able to say well look they're saying
this but they don't really believe this
it's just actually another way to
manipulate their voters no this is
internal stuff folks this is polling
these are training sessions that the
democrats are giving to their candidates
and they're saying shoot
man this critical race theory stuff this
transgenderism stuff in the in the
classrooms the all the cultural stuff
it's it's really not working for us and
it's really working for the republicans
right
republicans should take note
think about the virginia election the
gubernatorial election there glenn young
glenn younkin ran initially as a
standard run of the mill just cut my
taxes chamber of commerce republican and
he was going nowhere fast and then when
he focused on issues that people
actually care about how how our public
schools now are trying to turn a little
johnny into little jane little
five-year-old boys they're trying to
convince them they're girls letting men
go into the girls bathroom what happened
there was a rape that was covered up in
a high school in virginia and what did
the superintendent do not only did he
cover it up there he moved the kid to
another school it happened again
that kind of craziness
along with other culture war issues
along with the lockdowns and the masks
and the vacs and immigration and all
sorts of other issues they play
for
the republicans
immigration is probably the best example
of this
there are two opinions that you're
allowed to have
on immigration if you are an elite
politician if you go to fancy places
this is both parties the one position is
we need to
knock down whatever remaining borders we
have let everybody come in oh we're
taking three million immigrants a year
it should be four five six or seven
there should be no limit on immigration
that's the left-wing position
and to some degree the kind of left
libertarian position
the right wing position
that you're allowed to have in elite
politics is
yeah we should have a ton of immigrants
yeah we should have more and more and
more immigrants but it's got to be legal
right this was even the trump position
trump was the most immigration
restrictionist presidential candidate
that we have had in my lifetime
serious major presidential candidate
and his argument was i want more
immigration than ever but it's got to be
legal
illegal bad legal legal good
that is completely out of touch with the
american people there is a new study
that just came out
sure and there have been studies showing
this sort of thing for years that the
majority of americans want to
dramatically reduce not just legal
or not just illegal rather but legal
immigration as well
there was a harvard harris poll three
four years ago showed that they that the
majority of americans including people
from both parties want to dramatically
reduce
that kind of immigration well this new
poll shows 69 percent of republicans 69
of republicans want to reduce legal
immigration
there there is no issue
no other issue in this country where the
discrepancy between the popular opinion
and the opinion of politicians in both
parties is so great
and so why is it because the left-wing
politicians want to flood the country
with foreign nationals because they
think that it will give them an
electoral advantage and frankly they
know that it will give them an electoral
advantage because all the polling shows
that immigrants and children of
immigrants who will have birthright
citizenship and even the grandchildren
of immigrants are overwhelmingly going
to vote for democrats maybe we can pull
some over to republicans but the the
trends if you just flood the country
with enough foreigners you're going to
give an advantage to democrats and why
do the republicans go along with this
the republicans go along with it on the
legal immigration front because they're
afraid of being called racist of course
it doesn't make you racist to say that
countries should have borders and we
can't just take the entire world in and
still maintain our culture but
republicans go squishy on that they're
so afraid look at the numbers folks your
voters want you to do this people in the
middle want you to do this even many
democrats want you to do this get wise
the the elite game is rigged don't take
the bait give the people what they want
a policy that also happens to be right
and just and in the national interest
you know
i don't maybe it's just because our
politicians these days are not as
educated as they used to be okay if you
want to get educated you can check out
ben's new book club that's right
ben has a new book show it's coming out
every third thursday
ben is going to be uh reading a book he
just did 1984 by george orwell this is
not your average book club ben is going
to help you experience the greatest
books ever written you're going to do it
together live it's it's totally taking
place live it's kind of like an all
access uh books like 1984 huck finn many
more
these are the works that shaped western
art and culture ben is going to show you
why third thursday book club allows you
to engage with ben like never before and
by the way
you're going to love the immersive sets
wait until you see what they created for
huck finn it's going to get everybody
canceled ben is gathering everyone
tonight 8 p.m eastern 7 p.m central
you're gonna get ben's personal notes
you'll be doing all of this with
thousands of daily wire members live so
right now sign up for the third thursday
book club at third thursday
thursdaybookclub.com
starts tonight 8 p.m central
uh 8 p.m eastern rather 7 p.m
central
speaking of ben ben got in a lot of
trouble
he got in a lot of trouble yesterday
he got in trouble with the bulwark for
those of you who don't know what the
bulwark is which i imagine is all of you
it's a group of those you know
former republicans who now oppose all
the republican candidates
it's the bill crystals and the charlie
sykes and the hardcore never trumpers
who pretended it was all about trump but
really they just left the gop they don't
believe in almost any conservative
perspective anymore and they spend all
their time shilling for democrats and
their whole operation is being funded by
leftists and democrats but they they do
so under the pretense that they are
still republicans they're the principled
republicans who don't believe anything
that republicans believe the principled
conservatives who don't want to conserve
a damn thing so ben got in big trouble
with them because ben
endorsed a law in florida the law in
florida
is
being misrepresented by leftists as a
don't say gay law
don't say gay what is what is it really
it says that
for extremely young school children
we're talking five-year-old six-year-old
seven-year-olds
they
cannot be taught radical sexual
ideologies in schools
so right now there's a problem in
schools where teachers are teaching
five-year-olds that they're they're if
they're little boys that they're
actually little girls and they're
exposing them to all sorts of creepy sex
stuff including gay porn like actual gay
porn i'm not being prudish here i'm not
saying that books that deal with
difficult or challenging themes are
completely off limits i'm talking about
like actual explicit obscene filthy porn
that would have been illegal in this
country until just a few decades ago
this is now being taught to five and
six-year-olds
and so
ron desantis speaking on behalf of the
people of florida of ordinary sane
people who don't want their kids being
indoctrinated into some creepy perverted
sex cult by radical leftists he stood up
and he said we're not going to have that
in the classroom
we're not going to have and and now
they're trying to present him as some
sort of radical don't forget today in
america if a teacher teaches the bible
in a classroom the most important book
ever written that has shaped our entire
civilization that teacher will be
punished probably fired may be
prosecuted but if a teacher teaches
explicit gay porn to five-year-olds they
will be celebrated
except in florida which is now looking
to possibly pass this bill so anyway ben
came out and
endorsed the bill of course he endured
any reasonable person any person with
two brain cells to rub together is going
to endorse this bill
and the principled
conservatives at the bulwark went crazy
prince conserving gay porn in in first
grade cons we're the principled
conservatives
conserving transgenderism transiting the
five-year-olds right
so this guy tim miller
wrote this this hit piece on ben tim for
those who don't know who he is which is
probably everybody
tim is the former
former press secretary for the jeb bush
for president campaign
didn't he's worked on a bunch of losing
campaigns and now he spends he's a
radical homosexual activist he seems to
be his big issue now is uh the ever
expanding lgbt lmnop rights and so he's
gone very much in that direction but
back before he was totally vocal about
that he was actually a spokesman for the
republican national committee
which tells you less about tim's
conservatism and more about the rn the
rnc which
has
had a lot of squishes work for it over
the years and it
uh it was reflected in a lot of big
republican losses
so
uh so anyway tim tim writes this piece
and he says this is awful this is don't
ask don't tell the schools it's very
important that we teach five-year-olds
all this creepy sex stuff is really
really important and uh you know if you
oppose that you're a terrible bigot
we're gonna side with the democrats the
reason i bring it up is not because his
article is worth reading it's not it's
not because tim miller matters he does
not uh it's it's not because ben needs
to be defended ben is expressing a view
that is not only correct but extremely
popular he'll be just fine the reason i
bring it up
is to show you how dumb it was
to let the squishes lead the party
okay how i just want to underscore the
point that the d triple c is making here
on the cultural issues
for some years you had the squishes and
the
kind of centrist libs like kind of
center right but kind of live the the
republicans who only cared about cutting
taxes they said okay
we'll team up with you actual
conservatives who actually want to
conserve a damn thing about our country
like our borders and our families and
our communities and our rights and our
way of life we'll team up with you
so long as we get to lead the show
so long as we downplay
abortion downplay marriage downplay
immigration downplay all the cultural
issues and all we talk about is cutting
taxes and then we'll we'll unite
together and then we're going to win now
while those people were leading the
party we mostly lost we would
occasionally win a little bit but we
mostly lost
all of our big wins were usually
attributable to
the cultural warriors getting to lead
the show a little bit thinking about the
contract with america in
uh 1994 i'm thinking about the moral
majority the religious right right they
they would tend to galvanize voters
these squish eggheads didn't do very
much but the other problem was when the
squishes and the eggheads and the just
cut my taxes republicans were leading
the show we social conservatives would
go along with it we said okay well look
it's a coalition that's the way the gop
works that's the way conservatives work
right and we would go along with it and
we'd follow these schmucks off a cliff
but then the minute the minute in recent
years that the cultural conservatives
got a little bit of their mojo back and
started leading things you saw it
especially with trump talking about
immigration talking about protecting
american jobs talking about things that
are much more cultural what happens
what happens these guys jump ship they
run away they suck up to the libs they
get all their funding for they cash the
paychecks from the libs they spend all
their time attacking republicans and now
they are saying to you that if you don't
want your little kid to get trans at
school
you don't want your little kid reading
gay porn in the in the third grade
classroom that you're a vile disgusting
bigot and you have no place in polite
society bye see you guys see ya bye bye
oh no what are we gonna do without the
five people
who who or the squish want to cut the
taxes republicans without doing anything
else this extremely small political
minority that has had a huge outsized
influence in the conservative movement
the republican party what are we going
to do without these guys i'll tell you
what we're going to do we're going to
win
that's what we're going to do without
them don't you don't need to believe me
the democrats know it too speaking of
cultural issues
china has just done something
that reminds me that even a broken clock
is right twice a day okay i don't really
i don't like china
communism is evil i don't like the
chinese government it's commits all
sorts of horrible atrocities it
suppresses christianity it's really bad
government
but china has just given me i think the
best argument that i've ever heard for
defecting from the west and moving to
china
they're censoring the 1990s sitcom
friends
this look
a stopped clock right
uh chyna is censoring friends
a very unfunny show i liked friends when
it was on the air
i was a kid i would watch it everybody
watched it it does not hold up i
recently tried to re-watch it it's
impossible when you compare friends to a
good tv show like frasier it's not it's
i don't even want to make the comparison
those two shows should not be
uttered in the same sentence okay
and uh friends obviously should have
been censored long long ago if not by uh
discerning private individuals than then
by the state and possibly the united
nations so china china has censored the
show they've taken out ross's ex-wife
because she's a lesbian
they took out references to her they
took out uh joey's references to going
to strip clubs and they kind of changed
some of that uh they take they took out
all a lot of the references to like
orgasms and things like that and made it
a little bit nicer uh
i'm only half joking when i say this is
pretty smart of china i'm only half
joking because while we as americans and
especially as conservatives have a
natural
aversion to censorship of any kind by
anyone forget the government but even
private individuals even institutions
it is worth remembering that just like
poetry requires limits so too does
liberty right
really bad poetry is the poetry that
doesn't have any rules good poetry is
sonnets right sonnets that have meter
that have rhyme that have numbers so
when you think of the great works of
hollywood ever made
they were made during a period when
hollywood censored itself when there was
something called the haze code it was in
effect from 1934 to 1968.
the the haze code produced some of the
greatest movies of all time in those
days we got movies like going with the
wind the wizard of oz mr smith goes to
washington stage goes great movies when
he got rid of it we got absolute trash
like friends the way that it was uh came
about was that largely catholic
conservatives convinced
hollywood to implement this code and
then protestant america loved it it was
once described as a jewish-owned
business selling catholic theology to
protestant america but it worked it was
great and we had good good movies back
then and i would much rather have the
wizard of oz and wuthering heights and
gone with the wind than crap like
friends so listen maybe we can learn
from our opponents even if that opponent
is china speaking of china tomorrow is a
really exciting day for the daily wire
because we will be releasing our new
show the enemy within
this docu-series features acclaimed
journalist and expert in national
threats lee smith he uncovers just how
far the ccp's infiltration of america
goes and a political coup orchestrated
by ruling elites to generate their own
wealth and power at the expense of the
american people's safety and freedom
each episode will take you deep into
what's going on behind the scenes what
those who are supposed to be protecting
you don't want you to know check it out
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within as you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that match the cruelty and wickedness
of medieval torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
the enemy within will start streaming
this friday february 18th exclusively at
the daily wire so if you are not a
member now is the time to change that
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe to join today also i cannot
stress this enough if you have not yet
seen the daily wires new movie shut in
you need to change that head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe get a membership
start streaming today it's streaming
exclusively for daily wire members it's
extremely popular with the audience on
rotten tomatoes so seriously head on
over go subscribe
we're creating more and more great
entertainment without a leftist agenda
it's all thanks to our daily wire
members go to dailywire.com subscribe
today so you can watch shut in hyperions
and gina carano's new movie coming out
this summer we'll be right back with a
lot more
speaking of authoritarian foreign
governments i know we're supposed to be
worried about china we're supposed to be
worried about russia invading i think
russia was supposed to invade ukraine
yesterday who knows i mean putin's still
moving troops all around but
the the
predicted wednesday invasion of of
ukraine did not did not occur as joe
biden told us it would
but the authoritarian government that i
am most concerned about at the moment i
don't know if you've heard of it it's
called canada it's a little closer to
home than china or russia it's sometimes
known as america's hat
and
canada is is really really clamping down
on civil liberties and canadians way of
life they are
justin trudeau is invoking the
emergencies
act this act allows him to basically
suspend
the rule of law in canada and go after
people who are protesting namely these
truckers they're freezing the truckers
bank accounts they're suspending
movement all sorts of the suspending use
of property
really really scary stuff well
the the people at lower levels of power
in canada and in the united states are
teaming up to push back on this
u.s governors and canadian premiers kind
of like the canadian version of
governors have just signed a letter
urging joe biden and justin trudeau to
drop the vaccine mandate for truckers if
you drop the vaccine mandate or if you
reinstitute exceptions to the vaccine
mandate then the trucker protest goes
away
if you if you drop this
insistence that all of these guys take
the fouchy algae this experimental drug
that doesn't do what everyone told us
that it was going to do for
to possibly protect against a virus that
doesn't pose a grave threat to most
people then if you just drop that you
get your supply chain back you get
people to go back to their normal way of
life
you've got now two premiers 16 governors
sent this letter to the top levels of
canadian and u.s leadership requesting a
very simple thing give us back the
exemptions
and you get your supply chains back
right now
the institutional force the
institutional power is all with the libs
and with the mandates and with joe biden
and justin trudeau
right the media the universities the big
tech platforms the corporations the
government everything all the
institutional power is with
the mandates
the people are against the mandates and
the people still have a little bit of
power in canada in the united states as
well and the greatest evidence of this
is that it's not just conservatives
coming out against this stuff
it's not just the right
that's coming out against
the
the
government and the political
establishment that's going to the
truckers
even ilhan omar
a radical leftist by the standards of
our government
member of the squad the john lennon of
the squad
is coming out
against this
and in a way in favor of the truckers in
a way
she was responding
yesterday on twitter to
a journalist who came out and was was
exposing small business owners who had
donated small amounts of money to help
the truckers
ilhan omar
retweeted this leftist journalist and
said i failed to see why any journalist
felt the need to report on a shop owner
making such an insignificant donation
rather than i think probably other than
to get them harassed
it's unconscionable and journalists need
to do better credit where credit is due
ilhan omar's absolutely right 100 right
this journalist
quote-unquote journalist is just acting
as a political operative to go after
then using this journalist's
institutional power to go after small
business owners who won't bow down to
the government and and the ruling regime
in canada and the united states that's
that's squashing these truckers
and telling everyone they have to take
this experimental
drug now why is ilhan omar doing this is
it because omar has had a moment of
moral clarity is it because ilhan omar
is about to become a republican you're
gonna you're gonna have joe manchin
maybe he could become a republican
kirsten cinema
maybe probably she's in and ilhan omar i
don't think so
it actually makes perfect sense that
ilhan omar would defend so at least sort
of defend the truckers and go after
these lib journals who are just shilling
for the regime why because ilhan omar is
a real leftist she's a real old-school
leftist what you are seeing right now
play out with the truckers issue
is something you saw with bernie sanders
decades ago on an issue like immigration
or even guns which is the difference
between the old left and the new left
the old left
all of it is
heavily influenced by karl marx but the
old left saw the big divisions in
society the big political question as
one of class the proletariat versus the
ruling classes the bourgeoisie
the
the working class the underclass they
weren't the workers of the world were
not uniting they were all mixed up in
their divisions on race and things like
that and so they couldn't unite and
throw off the chains that enslaved them
the new left is much much more focused
on race and sex on all of these kind of
nasty intersectional identity issues
right that's what they're focused on
ilhan omar even bernie sanders will
speak to both sides of the left right
now but here ilhan is siding with the
old left this is why bernie sanders has
been for almost all of his career he's a
he's a hypocrite no contradict himself
and he's he's a slimy politician just
like anybody so he'll he'll sometimes go
back on his promises but for most of his
career bernie sanders has been
anti-immigration because he observes
that immigration lowers the wages of the
working class disproportionately it's a
way for fat cat capitalist plutocrats to
line their own pockets and not have to
pay such high wages to workers
and who gets screwed it's the little guy
so bernie has been generally an
immigration restrictionist for his
career at least relative to other people
in his party
well
now we're seeing this play out with
ilhan omar this ilhan omar is clearly
reading the d triple c missives she's
clearly reading the democrat playbook
which is saying guys cut it out stop
supporting all these radical insane
cultural issues just be it culturally be
kind of normal here guys
it's a bad look when you're siding with
plutocrats with globalist elites over
truckers man if you're the party of the
workers and you're coming out against
truckers who are the lifeblood of the
economy who are moving goods from place
to place who are as blue collar as blue
collar gets you're against them
it's really hard to say you're the party
of the worker it's actually impossible
so ilhan omar good honor i mean she made
the right call here but really she's
doing it from self-interest her own
personal political self-interest and the
self-interest of her party fortunately
that the rest of her democrat colleagues
haven't really gotten the memo even
after the memo went out they still don't
seem to have gotten it
the old left versus the new left you're
seeing a big political shift go on right
now it brings me to
a kind of more insidery political story
but i do want to acknowledge it the
political writer the satirist pj
o'rourke died a couple of days ago
a lot of people especially younger
conservatives probably won't remember
p.j o'rourke
p.j o'rourke got to start with national
lampoon a lot of younger listeners
probably won't even know what that is
and so he was a comedy writer but he was
he was
really he's shown
in the realm of political satire i used
to read his stuff a lot especially when
i was younger he has a famous essay
called how to drive fast on drugs while
getting your wing wang squeezed and not
spill your drink it's a very he was
talking about that kind of republican he
said we're republican party reptiles you
know we're we're interested in uh in
kind of doing a lot of drugs and going
out and it's really sort of 1980s
american psycho kind of conservatism if
you want to call it that was really
funny he was a really tremendous writer
you might call him the voice of a
generation really i think you could call
pj o'rourke the voice of a generation of
movement conservatives
and extremely talented and his essays
still hold up and they're funny
but pg o'rourke's perspective which was
much more individualistic do whatever
you want you know drive fast on drugs
while getting your wing-wag squeeze to
not spill your drink
that is not where the conservative
movement is now and it's not where the
gop is now and he knew it
i'm i'm
i promise you i'm not speaking ill of
the dead i have a great deal of respect
for pg or work but he knew it and he
sort of defected in his later years he
came out against donald trump in 2016.
he said i'm going to vote for the
democrat i'm going to vote for hillary
and he even did that in a very funny way
he instead he said i endorse hillary
clinton and all her pomp and all her
empty promises is comparing her to the
devil in the baptism right he's saying
she's the devil but she's the devil i
know and trump trump is the devil that i
don't know and i'm not comfortable
voting for him he was much more focused
on
you know let let people do whatever they
want let people keep their money do
whatever they want and
i think that plays very well especially
in satire but it's not where the
conservative movement is right now and
it's i think it's why he kind of pulled
back from the right in the gop and the
conservatives in in the latter years of
his life and this is what you're seeing
from the poll after poll the gop on
issues like immigration from the d
triple c playbook that's not where we
are if republicans want to win so
i say that i'll put a button on that
r.i.p a pgr work i encourage people
they'll you'll if you go back and read
his essays you're going to really enjoy
it he's very very funny
but there's a there's a lesson here too
from the past few years which is about
where is politics going if conservatives
and republicans want to win now it's all
about
culture and it's about it's about a
little bit more than just do whatever
you want it's about what should we do
we're looking at a at a society that is
the product of do whatever you want
for 50 years do whatever you want on the
left meant screw whoever you want and do
whoever you want on the right meant
screw whoever you want economically
on the left it meant literally on the
left it was the sexual revolution and if
it feels good do it and then on the
right what it meant was just ruthless
competition
total deregulation of everything there's
no such thing as the common good forget
it when the founders are talking about
the general welfare that's all crazy
we're just going to endorse you know ein
rand radical individualism you know
greed is good 1980s kind of
semi-ironic semi-earnest stuff and
we're living in the culture now very
selfish culture where the institutions
that once held up our society have
almost all broken down no one has any
belief in them anymore we don't even
believe in our elections the republicans
haven't but what they've disbelieved
at least two elections in the past 20 or
so years right they they didn't believe
in the 2000 election some didn't believe
in the 2004 election
uh they certainly didn't believe in the
2016 election
and then republicans don't believe in
the 2020 election
you know the one where they actually
changed all the voting rules right
beforehand anyway
we don't believe in that
the family is broken down communities
broken down we don't know what it means
to be an american anymore we don't have
a common language we don't have national
borders we don't what do we have well
that's the result of a country that
doesn't pay any attention to the common
good and the common things the things we
hold in common that's what republic
means folks it means the things that are
held income race publica the stuff we've
got together what do we have together i
don't know we're going to need we're
going to need
to answer that question if you're a
conservative you now need to answer not
just
what should we cut
what should we
stop paying attention to what should we
not revere i think we've got to start
answering what should we do
what what are not just what are our
rights but what are our duties what are
our obligations what are the things the
sacrifices required of us to continue to
have a country
what we are not
is the party of the squishes if we want
to win uh recently larry hogan who is
the governor of maryland he was now
running for senate i guess in maryland i
don't know i don't even pay attention to
larry hogan larry hogan is a total
squish lib anti-trump republican and and
i'm not saying by the way i'm not saying
all those things are synonymous i think
there there was a kind of principled
argument against trump at least in the
the first election when people thought
he might be kind of a liberal and he
didn't really know exactly what he was
doing
but
but but i think just like tim miller and
the bulwark show us it was never really
about trump
it was about you there was that great
meme during the 2020 election where was
trump sitting there he said they're not
after me they're after you i just happen
to be in the way and i think in many
ways that's right it's not it's not just
about trump
if you oppose
transiting the kids in schools you're
now considered a vile terrible bigot
worse than the orange man
and so anyway larry hogan is one of
those kinds of squishy conservatives he
was on cnn
of course
he was on jake tapper's show and jake
tapper was typically insulting
republicans and the conservative
movement where the party is and he said
so larry
you know larry are you considering
running in 2024 and larry hogan
unbelievably able to keep a straight
face says well i'm considering it
it's a nice video it just lacked the
hogan 2024 banner at the bottom are you
considering a presidential run well we
put out great videos like that almost
every week that was taken from my state
of the state address last week and it's
pretty well done but like i said i'm
going to be i'm going to run through the
tape as governor until january of next
year
i'm going to try to be the very best
governor i can be i'm going to continue
to stand up and be a voice i'm not going
to sit back and not be involved in the
issues of the day i'm concerned about
the direction of the party in the
country and i'll make a decision about
2024 after i finish this job so you are
considering it so we're certainly going
to take a look at it after january of
23. what makes you think that there's uh
a lane for a
moderate ish
uh blue state anti-trump sane republican
like you when you look at your party
right now well you know i consider
myself a common sense conservative i
have been a lifelong uh republican
i i believe that that's where most
people in america are about 70 percent
of the people in america are completely
frustrated with politics on both sides
republicans and democrats and latest cnn
poll came out and said you know right
now only 50
of the republicans would like to see
donald trump run again i believe that
there is a pretty large lane of sane
republicans uh and they're looking for a
voice
at hogan 2024 are you in are you in with
larry i don't think anybody is i don't
even know if larry is in with larry
larry hogan
the
kind of liberal squishy republican from
maryland he is floating at 2024
presidential campaign
he's doing it of course on cnn because
that's where his audience is his
audience is not on the daily wire his
audience is not his constituents are not
at the blaze or fox news or newsmax or
oan they're not there they're on cnn so
he goes on cnn and jake tapper
besmirches his
ostensible constituents and colleagues
and party the conservatives and the
republicans because they're insane
aren't they and and larry young says oh
yeah well i think look i think there's i
think people want a sane republican okay
like me they want a moderate person
who's really squishy who's just gonna
possibly cut your taxes that's what they
want don't they
no
no they don't they don't
i think 70 of america i think the
majority of america just they're
basically just chamber of commerce
republicans no nobody's a chamber of
commerce republican there are like seven
of them in the whole country
do you know where the majority of
republicans are actually i'm sorry the
majority of americans the overwhelming
majority of republicans but the majority
of americans
they want to stop legal immigrants from
coming into this country forget illegal
obviously they don't want those the
illegal immigrants too that is
considered a far-right fringe position
by people like larry hogan
that's where the majority of americans
are
i don't think the majority of america do
you know where the majority of americans
are on transing the bathrooms and
transiting the kids in elementary
they're saying no get this crap out of
our schools but the moderate republicans
are saying oh no no well let's listen we
need to be open-minded maybe
maybe we should mutilate children i
don't know asa hutchinson remember him
he's another squish republican in
arkansas he said look we need
to allow
uh parents to kind of make these
decisions with doctors if they want to
trans their kids that's fine we need to
let the
even even christie gnome she's since
reversed course on this but even christy
nomap in south dakota was was for
letting men compete against women in
college sports the vast majority of
americans think this stuff is completely
insane
i the the conventional elite wisdom
wisdom quote unquote
the wisdom of our world the wisdom of
our age
is
telling us
that there's a huge appetite in america
for just cut my taxes and let the
corporations do whatever they want and
don't have anything to say about virtue
or nationhood or citizenship or what our
country is
nobody wants that nobody no there is not
the only people who will benefit from
larry hogan 2024 are the predatory
campaign consultants who will build a
bunch of completely out of touch
squish billionaires center right leave
me alone just cut my taxes billionaires
out of a lot of money or or even 100
millionaires or 10 millionaires
depending on how good a pitch larry
hogan can make
and they'll make they'll pay themselves
these consultants will make nice
six-figure salaries and then larry hogan
will give up
this is not
listen to the democrats folks
listen not only to your constituents
listen to your opponents who are telling
you
where the wins really are
i don't i don't want to hear about
listen we just need to
we just need to get along
we just we need to stop being so
so
forceful and aggressive in our political
maneuvers we need to stop we need to
stop being so cultural here's what i
want to hear about here's what i want to
hear about
donald trump said that the democrats
spied on him when he was a candidate and
when he was
the president
all the squishes laughed at him and they
all went on cnn and they all mocked him
and they all opposed him and then it
turned out it was completely true
clinton associates hillary clinton
associates spied on donald trump at
trump tower at his campaign
and at the executive office of the
president this is a major major crime
we know this from john durham's report
the doj now we have found out that the
biden campaign
has hired the same firm that did the
same spying on donald trump as president
the biden campaign paid this cyber
security firm seems like the opposite of
cyber security twenty thousand dollars
the only two presidential campaigns that
this firm has ever gotten paid for
or paid by rather are the clinton
campaign and the biden campaign
i want to look into that i i will not
support
a presidential candidate
who does not promise to get to the
bottom of that to look into that yeah
good cut my taxes i do i want you to cut
my taxes but yeah sure
yeah okay
get some good trade deals
i want to root out this rank political
corruption because our opponents
are running roughshod over our
our political order not just the issues
but the order the institutions the power
centers and we're not doing very much
about it
who is still working with this cyber
security firm what campaigns i want to
know the names of those campaigns
what levels are they at are we talking
about congress are we talking about
senate is joe biden still working with
this campaign i want to find out i want
to subpoena the people who are working
with this campaign i want to find out
what they knew and when they knew it
i want names and i want accountability
the white house is completely
stonewalling
so occasionally you'll have a real
question asked in the white house
briefing room the deputy press secretary
corrine jean-pierre was asked this
question she said no no no nothing to
see here la la la go talk to the doj
this news about the durham investigation
um does the president have any concerns
about a candidate for president uh using
computer experts to infiltrate computer
systems
of competing candidates or even the
president-elect to you for the goal of
creating a narrative is that something
that
that's something i can't speak to from
this podium so i refer you to the
department of justice
in that report monitoring
internet traffic
is is that spying again i can't speak to
that report you i i refer you to
department of justice generally speaking
that with monitoring and internet
traffic i need my answers that i could
change i refer you to department of
justice i can't speak to that from here
la la la la la talk to the department of
justice la la la la la i can't hear you
okay uh karine you won't tell us how
about you jen saki what's going on what
about this huge plus probably the most
egregious political scandal in our
nation's history you guys were even
working with the firm you got anything
to say about it
do you know if there's still a system
picking up
server data on the eop and if not
when it stopped again i know you asked
my colleague a few questions about this
the other day but i would point you any
questions about this at the department
of justice and then is what was
described in the filing there
monitoring internet traffic is that
generally speaking would that be
considered something
along the lines of spying again i would
point you to the department of justice
same answer they talk to the lawyers
they're workshopping this as they're
sticking to their script okay because
they know that the republicans have
these democrats
dead to rights there's a benefit here
for the biden campaign which is that
biden is extremely unpopular hillary's
being floated as a candidate so i think
they're fine to throw hillary under the
bus but they're implicated too because
they worked with this this firm as well
they know
that their views are unpopular they know
that their record is very very unpopular
they've got no good answer on this the
only way that they think that they're
going to win here is by stonewalling
gaslighting and cheating so they're
going to say la la la la la stop it stop
pushing stop pushing that's how you know
we are right over the target got to keep
pushing harder i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
michael knowles show is produced by ben
davies executive producer jeremy boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 22. on the matte wall show
we talk about the things that matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show